let's talk about that decay in a more
material sense we got the story from
cnbc hiring falters in december as
payrolls rise only 199 000 though the
unemployment rate fell to 3.9 percent i
love this because the story was
published on a friday and for those that
aren't familiar friday is when you
announce stories you don't want anyone
to hear because they're not paying
attention because this is bad news but i
think when we're talking about any kind
of state of decay talking about what's
going on with the economy what's going
on with money printing and jobs is a
really big part of it and i know uh
especially you mike have tons of
experience with how the the the jobs uh
market and labor works in this country
or doesn't or doesn't you know look it's
a uh
it's a funny thing the
the existence of
opportunity is an inconvenient truth for
a lot of people and my foundation we
started 13 years ago just trying to make
a more persuasive case for a few million
good jobs that existed that nobody
wanted right it was really just better
pr
for welders steam fitters pipe fitters
mechanics and so forth these 11 million
jobs that are currently open right now
the vast majority don't require a
four-year degree they require training
so
you're you're probably old enough to
remember shop class was a thing
once upon a time shooting club was too
that's right yeah and homeek was too yes
like real skills
and whether you were into that or not
you know the fact that they existed in
high schools gave a whole generation
a front row seat
to the optics of labor you could at
least
look at a job and understood
understand at a glance that it exists
right that doesn't happen anymore we
took shop class out of high school and
that by the way was no no mean trick
right it used to be the vocational arts
so we took the art out of it called it
votec changed votech to shop then we
walked it around behind the barn and
shot it in the head and when we did that
the unintended consequences
we're still seeing them people wonder
why college is so expensive well hell we
just spent 50 years telling an entire
generation that they're completely
screwed without a four-year degree
so we free up a bottomless pile of money
to borrow in pursuit of that degree
meanwhile we affirmatively tell that
same generation that there's a whole
category of jobs that are beneath you
which surprise surprise just happened to
be the very jobs that are currently
going begging right now so we're lending
money we don't have to kids who can't
pay it back to training for jobs that
don't exist anymore and that's what that
headline's all about yeah people don't
seem to understand this when we talk
about they they say you know four
million people unemployed or what what
is the number four and a half million
people quit their jobs last month
last month quit their jobs dude
and then you have 11 million job
openings and so
people who look at that at a you know a
cursory glance they don't understand
somebody who quits their job as an
insurance broker or middle manager at a
cracker factory can't go become a
petroleum engineer or even a plumber so
there may be a job opening in certain
trades or in certain industries that
don't correlate so we have we have that
problem i i feel like there's something
fascinating in my experience with a lot
of uh people of my generation
millennials where they don't understand
basic economics and i don't mean the
math i mean quite literally how to come
about resources and food
so you know i talked to the average
person from my hometown or that i've
that i you know that i know went to
college and their idea is if i want to
pay rent if i want to eat food i have to
get a job and in order to get a good job
i need a degree
whereas my mentality has always been i
suppose maybe because i raked leaves for
money or mowed lawns or or shoveled snow
you know growing up in chicago if i
needed money i'd have to go figure out
how i can do it so i'm a little kid and
so you know i asked my dad like what do
we do i want to buy a toys like we'll
get make money like how and he's like i
don't know figure it out so me and my
brother we we make cool leg we go to the
we go to the park and we have a pitcher
and we'd sell glasses of kool-aid at the
baseball games or we'd get take a rake
and go ask people if they want to give
you money and i knock on doors hey i'm
willing to do a job for you in exchange
for money i didn't need a degree i
didn't need it need to go and ask an
employer to employ me or fill out forms
it was literally i could ask another
person if there was an exchange to be
made i feel like our generation my
generation doesn't understand that well
they're being given a binary choice and
it's
it's it's a false choice right it's not
one or the other
i remember in the debates rubio
said something he said um
he said what the country needs are or
fewer philosophers and more welders
and my social blew up my foundation blew
up they were like hey this guy gets it
he's saying what you've been saying and
i said well
actually no i i i'm not saying the
problem with society is too many
philosophers i'm saying it would be nice
if we had more philosophers who could
run an even bead and it'd be nice if we
had more welders who could talk
intelligently about nietzsche and
descartes and it's not like one or the
other you can't say oh look i'm going to
be a leaf raker and not be curious about
the rest of the world the thing i didn't
have when i went to community college in
1980 was this thing right i didn't have
this little handheld device that ties me
into 98 of all the known information in
the world so if i just have a healthy
sense of curiosity and an internet
connection all right well guess what two
weeks ago i watched the lecture at mit
for free now that thing would have cost
thousands of dollars
but it's now
it's all available virtually for free to
anybody and so if you look at it through
that lens the idea that we're still
saying that the most expensive path is
the best path for the most people
that's a big lie and that's messing
stuff up there's a great there's a great
joke real quick
someone posted on reddit once if you
could go back in time and say one thing
to shock the people of the past what
would you say
and someone commented i have in my
pocket a device which grants me access
to the summation of human knowledge i
use it to argue with strangers and look
at pictures of cats
that's a great quote i definitely don't
want to generalize too much but mike i
wanted to ask you this college is raking
in so much money with
with them indebting so many children
brainwashing so many of them a lot of
people are arguing that colleges by and
large cause more harm than good what's
your kind of understanding of that uh
especially when it comes to the current
situation in this country which i would
say is in part responsible because of
this indoctrination system which some
people call an education system well
there it is just just once i would like
to be able to to say what i mean and not
have somebody hear it and hit it back
over the net in terms of micah's
anti-education i'm not for the record
i'm going to be as clear as i can on on
your podcast if if you're
if if you're not educated you're screwed
all right now having said that if you
think the only place you can get an
education is a university
you're screwed in a different way
that's
that's the big deception we've got it
baked into our heads that the only place
to get a worthwhile education
is the most expensive place in the world
that's why we have 1.7 trillion dollars
in student loans and obscenely that's
why we continue to hear about how those
loans ought to be forgiven
now this makes me crazy because in my
world
you know we've trained 400 people
through my foundation to work in
usually the construction fields those
are the most popular welders in
particular i know a lot of people who
have done really well who've gone
through the program and they're working
now and they've paid 40 50 000
to buy a truck they need their truck for
their business big old diesel truck you
know these things
they don't grow on trees nobody's
arguing to pay off the loan on that
truck
these are people who build our homes
these are people who keep the previously
aforementioned infrastructure running
these are people who are fighting on the
front line against the second law of
thermodynamics and we're not gonna
nobody's proposing for a moment that we
help subsidize the tool
that allows them to do that job and yet
we will argue
from the rooftops about why it's good
and fair to pay off a college debt what
do you think about paying off uh in all
the interest on all the college loans
and then make the
companies eat the interest you got to
clarify paying off just making it good
to zero the government is now the
government stealing money and using it
to pay for no no no no no
uh uh eliminating interest rates is just
interest rates okay you don't have to
get out
i'll give you specifics i have like 19
000 in student loan that i've had for 21
years i paid the minimum monthly and i
have more debt now at 21 000 than i did
21 years ago because i've just been
paying the minimum
um
i've also had it on forbearance at times
when i couldn't afford it which to me is
like if i just got that interest to zero
i don't like 12 grand because all
everything i paid is just paying back
interest this is i think similar to what
you were saying one of the issues i have
is i think the interest rates are are
predatory and a lot of young people are
being effectively ripped off so i think
there's a good middle ground and maybe
we can suspend interest rates but you
got to pay back what you spent something
like that but the issue is the way that
the narrative is framed why don't we
talk about any other debt why why is it
that we you know uh college degree
holders are some of the highest income
earners in the country so effectively
giving some of the wealthiest free money
or a forgiveness well let's talk about
other areas where we can you know better
the country or or give people some
relief you like ubi
do i like it yeah what do you think
about it i don't like it
and i and you know what and i i don't
have a great
reason other than
i don't believe the primary purpose of
work is transactional
i don't believe
i don't believe you guys are sitting
around this table
for the paycheck i'm sure you enjoy it
but
it's a crooked road that we're all on
and if you're only here for the money my
guess is you're not going to have much
of an audience money's a tool would
intend to get these cameras these
microphones and then the message is it's
a happiness
it's a symptom
of
of
of a well-intended and well-executed
plan you know unless you're born into it
well look that's
nobody starts this race at the same line
it's not fair i get all that i get all
that and as far as the interest goes
look i'm i'm really of two minds right i
i really
pity
genuinely pity the pressure that we've
put on a whole generation of kids when
we lean into them to sign on the dotted
line and and when guidance counselors
and parents and everybody forms you know
along with your peers
the the pressure to borrow the money you
borrowed is is really obscene in my
world now does that mean i think the guy
or the woman who didn't take that loan
who went a different way do i think they
should be on the hook to pay off one
penny of that i don't but i do think
we can do a much much better job of
informing
the next generation and i'm not saying
your problem doesn't matter it's it it's
a bad deal i know i was getting into it
when i got into it i didn't understand
compound interest to the nth degree but
i knew that there was going to be
compound interest and financial literacy
is part of this too teaching that with
homec and some semblance of a skilled
trade and you know getting a kid through
high school understanding compound
interest understanding basic skills
under teaching work ethic for god's
sakes you know there's a way to do it
what do you think is a great way for
young people to get into some sort of
trade right now or someone that maybe
has lost their job over the last two
years what's like a few starting steps
well look if you're if you're willing to
roll up your sleeves if you if you're
willing to learn a skill that's in
demand i can personally tell you right
now i don't know of a single
construction operation and i know
hundreds of them who aren't hiring like
crazy we have been trying to expand and
build and we are we are jammed up
because there's a labor shortage there's
a materials shortage so should a young
person just call cold call construction
companies and let them know i'm ready
listen i you'll find i'm very very
careful with
cookie cutter advice but
if it were me yeah i'd do what he did
i'd knock on doors and say i want to
make money and here's what i'll do i'll
show up early i'll stay late i'll take a
bite of the crap sandwich when it comes
along what do you need what skill should
i dedicate the next six months of my
life to learning if it's welding so be
it who's your best welder by the way
i'll work for free i'll start you tell
i'm telling you i've never seen this
kind of opportunity available and i will
get i'll catch all kinds of hell for
saying this because to your point
earlier
when we talk about the existence of
opportunity there's a giant tendency of
a lot of people to go
those jobs suck
those jobs don't pay enough that's
because your capitalist greedy rapacious
bosses
uh are just simply not offering a fair
wage and that's what my buddies on the
left say my buddies on the right say
universally well you know the skills gap
you know you got 11 million open
positions because people are
fundamentally lazy and shiftless right
so and that's that's the problem it's a
binary lie
spoiled might be another another word
describe some of these individuals one
one way uh one one thing i've often
talked about is
you know when i started doing the work
that i did i mean and luke as well
because we've i've you know been working
with luke for like a decade we're
sleeping on couches when i when i would
travel to other countries for work
related projects luke would be like hey
i'll come down let me crash on your your
hotel couch or whatever because it saves
money but when i talked to a lot of
these you know when i started working
for vice
so many people would say i want to do
what you do i want to travel around
and then i would tell them did you know
that i sleep on a couch right now when i
worked for vice and they were paying me
to fly around and report this news
and you know people assume it must be
this glamorous glorious job and i must
have i must be getting paid so much
money and i was sleeping on my buddy's
couch he'd wake me up at two in the
morning smoking pot being like what up
and like it was funny but it was
stressful at times and then i talked to
these other people that like i really
want to do that job and i'm like well
you know you're making money why don't
you go buy a plane ticket and like oh my
rent is two grand and i want to have
this really nice apartment in
williamsburg and i just feel like i
don't even have that yeah so what's
what's your priority
comfort it was comfort not not the
mission so you brought that point that
no one here is is doing this for the
paycheck and i'll say this too i mean
just the paycheck just the paycheck
you know uh as long as i've
known luke luke got started with like a
handicam and he was confronting
politicians and powerful elites because
he was passionate about it i got started
with a little tiny gopro i just put on
my computer screen and i would talk
about things i saw in the news that i
had feelings about from there you
planted a seed and i just wanted to keep
doing it i wanted to keep going i wanted
to keep traveling i wanted to keep
talking about stuff and somehow me and
my living room with a gopro turned into
we got all these cameras everywhere and
these lights and uh the the money was
was secondary to all of it it was
having a camera turned on talking about
what i think what i feel what i've
researched
proving the liars wrong fact checking
that's what i cared about now here we
are with the with a company we're
building more and i got to be honest um
money is is is
not a factor in what our plans are i you
know i i don't put together say the cast
castle vlog where we have you know the
chickens and stuff because i was like
man we're going to make so much money
money off this i was like i want to do
something cultural right we don't make
money off of it but we're having these
videos we're showing people behind the
scenes we're building culture we're
trying to inspire you know young people
that's everything we're doing and we're
fortunate enough to be able to expand
also we just launched a charity that uh
basically we're building decentralized
software social networking software so
people can host their own content and
have subscriptions directly without any
kind of middleman that's great without
censorship with that company i could
take 50 million and hire like 50
developers and start building a factory
where we'll mass-produce raspberry pi's
or something like it pre-loaded with the
software turn it around keep it pro if
they're willing to work and it's complex
to launch that system you needed like a
lot of prep and oversight thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you